Bueno ya llega la revista de prensa con
Marta Moya Marta última de la semana ya
bienvenida Gracias Rodrigo buenos días
Buenos días A ti también vamos a empezar
este repaso de nuestra revista de prensa
con un artículo del periódico
estadounidense en New York Times que
hace una comparación entre estas
acusaciones hacia Donald Trump y hacía
también el primer el ex Primer Ministro
británico Boris Johnson que nos cuenta
el Times pues Rodrigo buenos días buenos
días a todos los televidentes a la gente
que nos escucha en Spotify también que
siempre me dicen que recuerde este
saludo para
por allí vamos a empezar como decías con
el New York Times es un análisis de
marklander que titula Trump y Johnson
fueron acusados por incumplir las normas
pero solo uno perdió la confianza de su
partido ambos están en el centro de las
polémicas en sus respectivos países en
estos días y hay paralelismos entre el
exprimir británico y el expresidente
estadounidense recordemos que Boris
Johnson fue acusado mentir
deliberadamente al parlamento por el
escándalo del partida y que eran Estas
fiestas ilegales que se celebraron
durante el confinamiento en la pandemia
y Donald Trump es acusado de retener
deliberadamente documentos clasificados
y además de manipular registros
comerciales este análisis del New York
Times dice Tal cual el partido
conservador británico ha plantado cara
regularmente a Johnson Mientras que el
partido republicano sigue esclavizado
por el señor Trump la comisión de
investigación ha condenado al exprimir
británico y de no haber renunciado Boris
Johnson la semana pasada su escaño le
habría negado su entrada a la cámara de
los comunes durante 90 días el lunes se
decidirá si la cámara de los comunes se
el legislativo británico acepta esa
investigación que hizo el comité en
Estados Unidos ha habido Voces del
partido republicano contrarias a Donald
Trump sobre todo quizá la decisión que
más afecta al partido republicano que es
que Trump no reconociera los resultados
en 2020 sin sin embargo sigue gozando
una casi inmunidad absoluta en las filas
del partido y sigue siendo el candidato
mejor postulado para ganar la nominación
hay similitudes entre ambos casos Trump
dijo ser víctima de una casa de brujas y
Johnson también hizo acusaciones graves
respecto de la investigación en su
contratextualmente también este artículo
del Times dice el lenguaje de Johnson
era propio de Trump aunque con acento
inglés decimos que Johnson pues declaró
que esa investigación era tal cual una
basura un desvario y una sarta de
sandeces citado por el New York Times un
estratega político estadounidense que se
llama France lunch dice Trump ha
influido el lenguaje de otros líderes
mundiales condenando al mensajero como
ya lo hice lo hizo bolsonaro en Brasil o
Benjamín en Israel bueno es bastante
común últimamente eso de condenar al
mensajero pero me parece bastante
interesante las palabras que utiliza el
New York Times de que Trump tiene
esclavizado al partido republicano muy
fuertes palabras veremos también
desde luego y a ver qué sucede con ese
juicio que todavía tiene el expresidente
vamos ahora a cambiar de tema Marta
vamos un poquito más lejos nos vamos
hasta Japón y lo que cuentan los medios
japoneses de esta noticia que veníamos
avanzando ya en nuestros noticieros Y es
que el senado del país ha elevado este
viernes la edad de consentimiento sexual
de los 13 a los 16 años Así es destacado
el Times y por otra parte del Washington
post porque también todos los medios
internacionales se hacen Eco De esta
noticia efectivamente
de esta noticia que es casi histórica no
porque pues la legislación japonesa no
se tocaba referida al consentimiento
sexual desde el año
1907 una persona decía la ley japonesa
Entonces desde los 13 años estaba en sus
plenas facultades para decir si estaba o
no de acuerdo con mantener relaciones
sexuales también Cabe destacar que esta
era una de las leyes más bajas en los
países desarrollados y Japón lideraba no
que pues tenía una de las edades más
bajas en consentimiento sexual hay otros
países como Canadá o la mayoría de
Estados estadounidenses que la tienen
fijada en 16 años algo más preocupante
en Francia 15 años y Alemania e Italia
en los 14 hoy la cámara alta como
decíamos ha votado por unanimidad que se
eleve la edad de consentimiento a los 16
años y aclara también un poco los
requisitos de enjuiciamiento para
delitos de violación que las víctimas
estén bajo influencia del alcohol o las
drogas que tengan miedo o que los
perpetradores se hagan se aprovechen de
su estatus social también se penaliza
esta nueva ley tomar fotos de
explotación sexual sin consentimiento
Este cambio esta revisión de leyes
empezó no obstante en 2017 pero de una
manera muy laxa después en 2019 hubo
unas protestas bastante sonadas en el
país que se llamaron las manifestaciones
de las para denunciar esas absoluciones
contra abusadores sexuales un caso muy
paradigmático fue el de un padre que
violó a su hija que tenía 14 años y que
fue absuelto fue declarado No culpable
Aunque luego la fiscalía revisó el caso
apeló y el señor este fue condenado a 10
años de prisión la votación de hoy eso
sí no ha logrado el consenso para
redactar que todas las relaciones no
consensuadas sean violación y según
derecho organizaciones de Derechos
Humanos Mejor dicho Este es un paso que
todavía tiene que recorrer un camino
mucho más largo porque Japón sigue lejos
de cumplir con Los estándares
Internacionales en legislación de
violación de delitos de violación claro
Marta es que muchas veces hablamos de
Japón como una de las democracias más
avanzadas del mundo pero en algunos
temas como este llevaban bastante
retraso desde luego vamos ahora hasta la
región en Nicaragua porque el periódico
el país destaca un reportaje sobre un un
nuevo caso de encarcelamiento de un
periodista bajo condiciones totalmente
opacas sí Rodri nos referimos al
periodista local Víctor ticai el 6 de
abril este periodista local salió a
cubrir una procesión de semana santa que
estaban prohibidas por el gobierno de
Daniel Ortega y Rosario Murillo por esta
pugna y esta persecución contra la
Iglesia Católica la policía después
irrumpió en su casa lo detuvo sin hacer
mayores o sin dar mayores explicaciones
su familiar nunca supo que pasó con el
tema hasta este 9 de junio cuando Bueno
pues fue informada de que su hijo había
sido detenido por presuntos delitos de
propagación de noticias falsas y
conspiración para el menos cabo de la
integridad nacional ahora este
periodista afronta una pena de cárcel
entre ocho y 14 años
y Marta vamos a cerrar con una noticia
que es que cada vez que la leo no deja
de sorprenderme Y es que el periódico El
Tiempo de Colombia destaca que hay una
empresa alemana queriendo vender el
mortífero cruce del Darién entre
Colombia y Panamá como un viaje de
Aventura exclusivo que es lo que cuenta
el tiempo es bastante Espeluznante esta
noticia no es solo una empresa sino que
son varias empresas alemanas las que
están detrás de esta oferta de lo que
llaman tours VIP para atravesar el tapón
del daría en que recordemos es una de
las fronteras más mortíferas en el mundo
y uno de los cruces migratorios más
peligrosos lo han cruzado más de 100.000
personas en lo que va de año y este
tapón el avión dejó más de 30 víctimas
mortales el año pasado arzas empresas
venden estos tours por nada más y nada
menos que 3.600 euros y el seguro les
incluye un helicóptero en caso de que la
situación sea grave y dicen que
comunidades indígenas les acompañan en
atravesar este cruce tan mortífero hay
varios youtubers alemanes que ya han
patrocinado estos contenidos en YouTube
y en redes sociales y bueno lo que dice
el tiempo es que esto es una de las emer
gencias humanitarias más graves que
atraviesa el planeta en la actualidad y
que empresas alemanas estén aprovechando
es una absoluta vergüenza los escrúpulos
Marta no los compra el dinero Muchas
gracias por esta revista de prensa buen
fin de semana gracias